rodrigo hemos visto una serie de
carreras clásicas muy interesantes y con
participación latinoamericana que
podemos hablar de los ciclistas
latinoamericanos sobre todo en este
comienzo de temporada pues realmente han
tenido un inicio de temporada muy bueno
no sólo en estas clásicas empezó sobre
todo muy bien nairo quintana en vueltas
por etapas de una semana y en estas hoy
en esta vieja por ejemplo hemos visto a
daniel felipe martínez del colombiano
como cuarto por el líneas de nadie ya
sergio guita al campeón colombiano
también quinto yo de sergio guita quizás
esperaba un poquito más porque ganó la
vuelta a cataluña y en estas clásicas de
primavera que se le ajusta muy bien a
sus características como ciclistas
explosivos pequeños peleón yo esperaba
más pero es verdad que ha estado enfermo
después de ganar la vuelta a cataluña y
habrá que ver porque realmente empezó
muy bien la temporada daniel felipe
martínez pues está siendo una gran
sorpresa para la línea 2 de quieren a
díaz después de la caída de hagan bernal
y de que el gran líder del equipo y del
ciclismo colombiano pues tenga una
recuperación muy larga daniel felipe
martínez ha ganado la vuelta al país
vasco una de las principales vueltas
del inicio de temporada y está por ver
si será el líder de líneas grenadier en
el tour de francia' yo veo difícil que
sea el líder único seguramente lo van a
tener en cuenta porque está en muy buena
forma pero está también en tomás está su
compañero gates hay que ver yo veo
difícil que línea los gra nadie se lo
lleve como un líder jim único porque el
tour de francia es demasiado importante
como para jugársela a una baza de un
corredor que está demostrando mucho pero
todavía no se ha visto en esos primeros
puestos en una carrera tan importante
como el tour de francia